every guy wants to be a great husband if
you don't then there's probably
something wrong with you and you will
never have a great
marriage so how do you do it how do you
have a great marriage where your wife
treats you like a
king well she will automatically do it
if you treat her like a
[Music]
queen do you the Bible says in 1 Peter 3
3: 7 husbands live with your wives in an
understanding way showing honor to the
woman as the weaker vessel since they
are hirs with you of the grace of life
so that your prayers may not be hindered
now there are a lot of things that we
can talk about when it comes to being a
great husb but I want to focus in on
five important things and the first
thing is treat your wife like like a
queen it is so simple and yet so many
people do not realize this so many men
that your actions create the reactions
from your wife and you can test it for
example if you want her to make you
coffee in bed start doing it
first all you got to do is treat her the
way you want her to treat you if you
want more attention from her but don't
give her the attention she needs what do
you think is going to happen if you want
her to make you delicious food sometimes
but you never make food for her or take
care of your household chores then what
do you think is going to
happen if you live with her in an
understanding way knowing what she needs
fulfilling it then the chances are
extremely high that she will also
fulfill your need
but the husband is the leader so you
need to act first I'll say it again
treat her like a queen and she will
treat you like a
king wash her
feet when was the last time you actually
did something for your wife that she
really wanted or would like or is
marriage for you just about you a
selfish life the Bible says that the
husband is the leader of the home just
like Jesus is the head of the church
what kind of leader was
Jesus he led by example by serving he
gave his life for the church and he
washed the feet of the
disciples John
13:12 when he had washed their feet and
put on his outer garments and resumed
his place he said to them do you
understand what I have done to you you
call me teacher and Lord and you are
right for so I am if I then your lord
and teacher have washed your feet you
also ought to wash one another's feet
for I have given you an example that you
also should do just as I have done to
you now listen to this very important
part truly truly I say to you a servant
is not greater than his master nor is a
messenger greater than the one who sent
him if you know these things blessed are
you if you do
them if you have to wash other people's
feet think about them as more important
than
yourself then how more important is it
when it comes to your wife the wife that
God gave you to wash her feet because
remember you are now one flesh Mark
10:7 therefore a man shall leave his
father and mother and hold fast to his
his wife and the two shall become one
flesh so they are no longer two but one
flesh what therefore God has joined
together let not man
separate if you lead your wife the way
Jesus Christ leads the church then your
wife will gladly follow
you not because she feels that she has
to but out of love you're not the boss
you're the leader and you need to follow
the example of Jesus so you need to do
what you need to serve your wife number
three let go of your
pride it's one of the biggest problems
that marriages
experience is pride especially when it
comes to the man in the house when he is
arrogant and full of Pride full of that
self that Jesus says that you you have
to deny yourself pick up your cross and
follow Jesus that is a true man a
selfish man will never have a great
marriage listen to this
verse Philippians 2:3 do nothing from
selfish ambition or conceit but in
humility count others more significant
than
yourselves Let each of you look not only
to his own interest
but also to the interests of
others now this does not mean that you
should let your wife walk all over you
because you are the leader you lead by
example by following Christ by setting
the example it means that you lead her
according to God's word that's how you
set the example according to this verse
you put yourself in her shoes and
understand what she needs from you and
then give give it to her and a lot of
times that requires you to sacrifice
your own
desires and to put her needs above your
own and if you start to do that you will
see that she is starting to do the same
and it creates this amazing loving open
caring relationship where you both are
humble and willing to support each other
in whatever you
need number four never put your wife
above
God always put God first in your life
above yourself above your wife above
your kids above everything else in your
life if you do it God will be with you
he will bless you in everything that you
do he will take care of everything
Romans 8:28 says that God works all
things together for good to those who
are called according to his
purpose
especially when it comes to the big
decisions actually old the decisions of
your life but especially decisions
regarding your marriage your
finances your
children
career your
relationships in all of it you need to
put God first and follow his will and
then everything will work out the way it
should Matthew 6:31 says therefore do
not be angry ious saying what shall we
eat or what shall we drink or what shall
we wear for the Gentiles seek after all
these
things and your heavenly father knows
that you need them
all these things about clothing drinking
food these things are just examples of
the things that you worry about usually
God says that you don't need to worry
about it he's your father and he will
give you what you need if you put him
first listen to the next verse verse 33
but seek first the kingdom of God and
his is
righteousness that's the condition for
the promise that now
follows and all these things will be
added to
you of course you need to include your
wife in all your decisions talk to her
ask her advice because her role as the
wife is to support you right but your
wife is not smarter than God you are not
smarter than God so you talk about these
things communication so you know all
your options you bring it to the feet of
Jesus Christ you pray about it and you
ask him all right how do you want me to
handle this how do you want my wife to
handle this how do you want us to act in
this situation Proverbs 3:5 trust in the
Lord with all your heart and do not lean
on your own understanding in all your
ways acknowledge Him and He will make
straight your
paths it doesn't say in all your ways
acknowledge yourself or your wife or
what everybody else tells you it says in
all your ways acknowledge Him you as the
leader of the home you have the
responsibility to follow God's Will and
then it says and he will make straight
your paths that's the
blessing if your wife says one thing and
God says another thing then you should
not listen to your wife you should
listen to God for example if your wife
says let's go and buy this car and you
pray and know it is not God's will to
buy then don't do it she makes mistakes
you you also make mistakes but God never
make any mistakes and there's already so
much in God's word that he has already
revealed to us how he wants us to live
and so if we follow it if we walk in his
will he will bless us for example the
Bible says you have to discipline your
kids if your wife doesn't want you to
discipline your kids and you listen to
your wife and you don't do it God's not
going to bless you the consequences of
not obeying God because that is what sin
is it is not obeying God sin in its
Essence is not following God's word and
the consequences of that is always bad
so what do you think is going to happen
if you don't discipline your kids in
love and
truth then your children will not
respect you and will grow up into
selfish adults who think they always get
what they want when they want no matter
what they do even if it's bad evil
there's no
consequences and they always get away
with with it and doing that actually
helps their sinful flesh to grow even
stronger and that's how criminals are
created over the last few decades
parents have been disciplining their
kids less and less they're not listening
to the word of God and what is the
result you can see this new generation
compared to our generation they have a
lot less respect for their parents
they're very different and very
selfish and that is actually also a sign
that we're slowly moving towards the end
times 2 Timothy 3 but understand this
that in the last days there will come
times of difficulty for people will be
lovers of
self lovers of money proud arrogant
abusive disobedient to their parents
ungrateful
Unholy heartless unappeasable
slanderous without
self-control brutal not loving
good treacherous
Reckless swollen with
conceit lovers of pleasure rather than
lovers of
God having the appearance of godliness
but denying its power avoid such
people put God first in your life
discipline your children with love if
you do that while they're young they
won't stray from it when they are older
Folly is in the heart of a child but if
you discipline him it takes it out put
God first in your marriage in everything
that you do it is God's word that says
that you have to love your wife not when
you feel like it it's a command
it's an act of your will not just a
feeling the feeling a lot of people
focus on that kind of love is the OS
love sexual love the attraction
love there's also agape love which is
the unconditional love that God has for
us that's the love that you also have to
have for your wife to love her even when
you don't feel like it Ephesians
5:25 husbands love your wives as Christ
loved the church and gave himself up for
her true peace and joy come only from
God not from your wife your wife helps
but that kind of peace that surpasses
all understanding and that Joy even in
trials and tribulations that can come
only from God and you need to understand
this because there are a lot of couples
out there they blame their partner nurse
because they don't have a good life
instead of taking responsibility for
your own life and looking to
Christ your wife is not responsible for
how you feel all the time she does help
you to have a great life but it is your
responsibility and you need to look to
God to get that Fire Within You John
14 Jesus says peace I leave with you my
peace I give to you not as the world
gives do I give to
you let not your hearts be troubled
neither let them be
afraid you always get your purpose that
fire purpose peace fulfillment
everything that you need you can get
from Jesus Christ don't look to it at
your wife all the time and expect her to
give you everything the whole time
you're going to burn her out you're
going to be too clingy and she will get
tired of it I'll say it again true peace
and and joy come only from God and not
from temporary worldly things including
people and your wife Philippians 4:6 do
not be anxious about anything but in
everything by prayer and supplication
with Thanksgiving let your requests be
made known to
God in other words lean on God have a
good relationship with God talk to him
all the time this is where you get the
peace that's it pauses all understanding
which it says in the next verse verse
7 and the peace of God which passes all
understanding will guard your hearts and
your minds in Christ Jesus you know a
lot of men complain about their wives
they say things like she should be less
grumpy she should be more thankful to me
for working hard she should put on the
clothes that I want want her to she
should stop nagging me all the time she
makes being a mom her main personality
tra and she never gives me attention
anymore she should learn how to be more
hospitable to my family she should do
more in the
house she she she it's always easier to
look at others and blame others right
while some of those things might be true
and she might improve on it based on
God's word
did it ever occur to you that maybe some
of those things that she's doing is a
result a reaction reactions maybe more
because of your actions how you are in
the house she might be tired of giving
and giving and giving and not really
receiving anything from you the things
that she really
needs and she's just human and humans
are not perfect are you giving your wife
wife what she needs according to the
Bible 1 Peter
3:7 husbands live with your wives in an
understanding way showing honor to the
women as the weaker vessel since they
are HS with you of the grace of life so
that your prayers may not be
hindered this is so serious to God that
he's basically saying that if you don't
treat your
wife in an understanding way the way you
should according to the word of God then
your prayers will be
hindered you might be busy with
religious things you might even preach
in the church you might do your Bible
studies and do all these religious
things while they actually mean nothing
because your prayers that's hindered
because back home you and your
relationship with your wife is not good
you're not treating her the way you
should
some of you are too harsh with the wife
that God gave you this is
serious Colossians 3:1 19 husbands love
your wives and do not be harsh with
them guys we need to understand this if
we don't treat our wives right if we
don't lead them according to God's word
then our wives they have full right to
hold us accountable because they need to
support us right and that means when we
Stray From the Path they always put God
first right when we stray they have the
right to say hey come back on the path
that means they don't have to listen to
you if you say things that are not in
line with scripture but if you do say
things to her if you do lead according
to scripture then she needs to listen to
you because then she's just obeying
scripture
right Ephesians 5:22 says wives submit
to your own husbands as to the
Lord as to the Lord this is amazing
right because this is an example of how
our relationship is through Believers
with Christ right the church and Christ
how he came to serve how he loves us and
so this is as Paul puts it it is
profound
you get it it means that you never lead
your wife your household In the Flesh
you as John Peter David you don't lead
it as you want to you lead your wife and
your children as Christ leads the church
so don't lead them in the soul level
your own intellect your own emotions
your own will we going to do this no you
lead them through the spirit as Christ
leads the church in truth truth in love
in oh there's so much Beauty in that
kind of relationship that kind of
leadership and that includes forgiving
each other as well as Christ forgave you
you also need to forgive your wife
Ephesians 4:32 says be kind to one
another tenderhearted forgiving one
another as God in Christ for gave
you marriage is awesome one of the best
things things you will ever experience
in this life if God is in the center and
if all these four types of Love is in it
as
well St family love poo friendship love
OS sexual attraction love and Agape
unconditional sacrificial
love a marriage is the only relation
ship with these four types of love in it
and Agape is the most important because
that is unconditional sacrificial love
you sacrifice your own life and you put
your wife her needs above your own
that's the kind of love
where you have an amazing marriage this
is where you choose to always love your
wife no matter what because it is not a
feeling it is an act of your will and
you have no excuses because if you are a
true reborn Christian you have God's
spirit in
you that means you can produce the fruit
of the
spirit and one of it is love Galatians
5:22 but the fruit of the spirit is love
the first one then
joy
peace
patience
kindness
goodness
faithfulness now go and produce this
fruit in your marriage love your wife
the right way lead your wife the right
way and be a great husband and if you
haven't subscribed yet then please
subscribe we bring out videos every week
and um there might be some ones here
that you might like and I'll see you
there and always remember this life is
short so don't waste yours bye guys guys